Hi everyone, welcome to this series of videos
for the topic of vectors.
This chapter is important for mathematics
and it also forms the basis for the next chapter,
that is 3-Dimensional Geometry.
There will be series of videos for this topic.
In this first video, I will just like to talk
about very basic stuff.
I will try to define vectors.
I believe that there is a lot of confusion
among students about even basic things like
position vector, line vector, unit vector
and magnitude.
I think if you can really focus on this video,
and try to understand the different between
position vector, line vector — that will
clarify a lot of things for you.
Let me start by defining the position vector.
First, before I go into position vector, let
me just briefly summarize vectors for you
in case you are not familiar.
I believe you have already learned about vectors
in chapter of physics like kinematics, forces.
You should know that vectors are quantities
that have both magnitude and direction.
And they are very important for scientific
studies in general.
Let me start by defining position vector.
So position vector, is a vector connecting
origin to a point.
And as the names suggest, basically this position
vector is about position of one point.
I think this is where a lot of students get
confused.
A good thing about vectors is that they will
be always be in 3 dimensions and they will
be really helpful in the next chapter of 3
dimensional geometry.
It is important for you to understand position
vectors and like line vector, unit vector.
So let us just initially focus on position
vector.
So what is the definition: a position vector
is a vector connecting origin to a point.
Let us say we have a point P with coordinates
Px Py Pz.
Let us call this x axis, y axis and z axis.
Position vector is a vector connecting origin,
which is O to the point P, and pointing in
direction on P.
This direction is very important because if
it is in the opposite direction, then the
vector will be opposite.
When we write OP vector (this is called OP
vector), the first letter is from where the
arrow line connects to second point (or the
second alphabet, which is P in this case).
OP vector also signifies the direction of
the vector.
What I am trying to say is that if you have
OP vector then the vector will start from
O and end at P.
In this case, OP vector means Px \i_cap .. (I
hope you are familiar with \i_cap: \i_cap
means the direction of x-axis) .. + Py \j_cap
+ Pz \k_cap.
So x axis, y axis and z axis.
Another point you might want to note is that
magnitude of OP vector is (Px^2+Py^2+Pz^2)^(1/2).
Let us do a quick example.
If we have a point
A with coordinates (3,2,1).
What is position vector and its magnitude?
And the answer is: OA vector = 3 \i_cap +
2 \j_cap + \k_cap and OA vector magnitude
= (3^2+2^2+1^2)^(1/2) = 14^(1.2).
Position vector is always for a point.
Please do not forget this basic definition
of position vector.
Trust me that it will happen sometimes during
the chapter of vector that you will get confused
if you forget this definition.
So please try to remember that position vector
is always and always for a point.
Now let us try to move to new type of vectors
called the line vector.
Position vector is for a point.
Line vector is for a line.
As simple as that.
If you have a line, let us say connecting
two points A and B.
If I write a vector here and b vector here,
what does this mean?
a vector is for point A and b vector is for
point B.
Whenever you see something like this in brackets,
it means it is for a point, or it is a position
vector.
In other words, a vector is OA vector and
b vector is OB vector.
And OA vectors and OB vector are position
vectors of point A and B.
Even this basic definition gets people really
confused.
So whenever you see a point and something
written in the bracket, that always means
a position vector.
So what does line vector mean?
Line vector means connecting two points.
If we have AB vector: starting from A and
ending at B.
Arrow goes from A to B.
This vector is defined as b vector - a vector.
Or in other words, AB = OB - OA.
Let us try to take one quick example to help
us understand this concept.
What is the vector
joining \sin(\theta) \i_cap + \cos(\theta)
\j_cap and (0,0,1).
What is its magnitude?
Let us try to find the answer.
It might be little confusing because of the
way it is written here.
\sin(\theta) \i_cap + \cos(\theta) \j_cap
is basically a point for which you have been
given a position vector.
\theta can be any parameter basically — \theta
is an angle and a parameter here.
We have not been given a value but we can
still calculate the answer.
b vector is \k_cap.
What will be b - a? It will be, \k_cap - \sin(\theta)
\i_cap - \cos(\theta) \j_cap.
And thus magnitude of AB vector would be similar
to the way we defined vector magnitude: squaring
all the components i.e. ( -\sin(\theta) ) ^2
+ ( - \cos (\theta) )^2 + 1^2 )^(1.2). And
\sin^2(\theta) + \cos^2(\theta) = 1. So AB
vector magnitude is 2^(1/2).
In this part I just wanted to emphasize that
line vector is for a line and position vector
is for a point.
Now there are also vectors which people get
confused about.
Here, both the vectors were fixed i.e. the
vectors started from A and went to B.
This started from O and went to P.
However, you should realize that sometimes
vectors are not fixed. They are only fixed in the
magnitude and the direction but aren’t fixed
in the position.
For instance, if I have been given a vector
a and I have been told that it is \i_cap +
\j_cap + \k_cap and I have not been given
any other information about this.
What would this vector represent? This vector
could represent a lot of things.
For instance, it can represent a point such
that OA vector for a point (1,1,1) would be
\i_cap + \j_cap + \k_cap.
Similarly, this can also represent a line
vector which it can be (b_vector - a_vector).
It can join two points and the difference
can come as \i_cap + \j_cap + \k_cap.
By free vector I just know the direction and
magnitude. It is free to translate in 3-D
space.
Let us say this is the vector. If this vector
freely translates — it is not changing its
direction and it is not changing its magnitude.
If you have not been specified whether a vector
starts from origin or a position, or it joins
two points, it can also be a free vector.
I want to emphasize this you will see later
in this chapter that many times people get
confused about free vectors as they are not
able to understand it. They also get confused
about the vector connecting two points, and
when they see notation — a_vector in the
brackets and b_vector in the brackets.
Just to summarize: whenever you see a point,
it always means a position vector.
Whenever you see a vector joining two points,
it means a line vector which can be calculated
like this.
Whenever you see something just written like
this and not specified whether it is a point
or whether it is a line vector, that means
it is a free vector which only has a fix magnitude
and a direction and can move freely around
the space.
Till now I have only talked about the magnitude
of the vector here: you can just take x_component
^ 2 + y_component^2 + z_component^3 and take
a square root of that.
However, there is something that is also important
for a vector and that is its direction.
So let me start by defining unit vector.
Whenever I write a vector_a, I can also write
vector_a as magnitude of vector_a into unit
vector.
What does this mean?
This means that a vector has some magnitude
which you can calculate by squaring x_component,
y_component, z_component, and adding them
and taking a square root. And this a_cap is
nothing but a unit vector.
Something which I really prefer to use is
to call it “direction”.
Unit vector and direction are synonymous.
So whenever you see a vector: it is multiplication
of its magnitude and its direction (or its
unit vectors).
For instance, if we have to calculate unit
vector of a_vector. Then you can write a_cap
as vector_a / | a |
Vector_a in this case is \i_cap + \j_cap +
\k_cap.
And | a | = (1^2+1^2+1^2)^(1/2), and this
means (\i_cap + j_cap + \k_cap)/3^(1/2).
In other words I can also write that a_vector
= 3^(1/2) ( \i_cap + \j_cap + \k_cap )/3^(1/2).
This is the direction, this is the unit vector
and this is the magnitude.
Let us write another question.
What is the direction of x-axis?
Direction means a unit vector. So in that
case a_cap would be direction or something
with the magnitude of 1. We know the direction
of x-axis is \i_cap and it also has a magnitude
of 1. So it is just \i_cap. \i_cap is nothing
but a direction.
So whenever I write Px \i_cap + Py \j_cap
+ Pz \k_cap, it means I have moved Px in the
x direction, and then I have moved Py in the
y direction, and then I have moved Pz in the
k direction.
That is how you define direction by unit vectors.
In this video we covered very basic stuff.
Position vector refers to a point.
Line vector refers to vector joining two points.
Free vectors refers to a vector which is neither
a point nor a line, and something that can
move freely around the space though it has
a fixed magnitude and fixed direction.
Unit vector means the direction where you
divide the vector by its magnitude. We did
a quick calculation to see that.
I hope this was clear. Just take some time
and digest these things. And in the next video
we will talk about addition of vectors and
section formula. Thank you.